foreign
[Music]
more than 200 years of military
non-alignments and applying to join
later
while May 18th Last year Sweden took his
story set to Pride the membership in
NATO together says
[Music]
terrorist organization in any way that
promotes strengthens or supports it
by delivering all the Lost parts of our
agreements
against all threats to its National
Security and condemn all terrorist
organizations including the pkk which
carry out the tax against it
we're living in an increasingly
dangerous World alongside State actors
terrorists or violent extremists all
supports a series that Sweden has been a
high terrorist threat since
2010. it's happening
intensive natural and international
efforts swings you and Allstate station
will facilitate our cooperation
and other operations
with foreign
foreign
thank you thank you very much
[Music]
to you
Russia's illegal offerings evasion of
Ukraine of course is now the battery off
to so much of our thinking it reminds us
of the importance of strong reliable
pressures and we have we all see the
huge Revolution that has taken place
because of the violence the changes
which in uh just a few years a change
was just a few years ago no one thought
possible as you say your own country has
set aside many many decades of
neutrality to apply to join NATO and I'm
very proud the UK has been a passionate
and local supporter of your session
process
where my position is clear that Sweden
must and shall
as soon as possible this Remains the
position we recognize the huge steps
that you as a country you have taken to
address the concerns of some of the
existing allies within NATO and the UK
very much is confident when we say that
all NATO allies will be made safer by
Sweden's drawing of Our Lives just as we
believe in Sweden
organization
your leadership
on the issue of supporting Ukraine as
the EU president has been exemplary
we notice the recent announcement of
sport package
and we pay tickets to the commitment to
Ukraine's recovery and reform that uh
president uh set out at the recent
Ukraine recovery conference in London it
shows once again that the UK both by
action you have seen in our relationship
with the EU it tends to remain a strong
and committed to the European partner
notwithstanding our departure from the
European Union
and we know the value that you bring
because of course we work closely and
regularly with you with you as partners
in the joint expeditionary course
uh later on this week and seeing
firsthand the association at work in the
Baltic
we saw earlier on how we find that we
have so much in common so many areas
where we are in natural alignment and we
will continue to find ways of working
together to enhance Army for prosperity
and security including of course on the
difficult issue of illegal migration
which is a person just an hour or two
countries but of course many other
countries in Europe as well
is a strong well into the future I'm
here today to reinforce that message and
continue with our work and it's a
pleasure to join you on this one find
thank you
thank you very much
well now we'll open up a globe for a few
questions please yes yes and the first
question goes to uh
in your view and also given that Sweden
considers that it is
requirements already in this memorandum
with turkey are you willing to work
within NATO to make this Prospect more
interesting so to say
and what are you willing to do
well
I think everyone can see how swiftly and
decisively uh Sweden and the Swedish
government have acted in response to the
conservative by one of the uh NATO
allies I think that that is something
which we should all recognize and the
point remains that Sweden as part of
NATO makes NATO stronger makes native
our eyes safer that is all about these
uh this is true of turkey as it is of
the
easily
[Music]
and the next question is
thank you the question to uh
regarding the
events taking place in Russia
for the last couple of days
what we preferable outcome of the uh
it's a change in leadership or something
else
well also by saying that I think that we
don't really have a reason to speculate
locally about this this is after all
something which has taken place in
Russia it's a domestic
and I think that we should call it as
such for myself I think also we should
be very cautious about the fact that the
thing which we should be focused on is
Ukraine and Lord Russia it is
war that we re-established a territory
Integrity of pain reaffirming
sovereignty and I think to either the
people of Ukraine his relief of a
terrible burden of this war this is
the aim of Swedish government and I
think that we are very well aligned with
this as well although I leave it to uh
Secretary General online
we find ourselves regularly
effort is alignment with uh
the response of the foreign
exclusively for the Russian people I
don't think it's healthy or useful to
speculates about what this might mean
for the leadership of Russia and
therefore I don't say but also it's
important that we focus on what we have
committed to which is supporting Ukraine
in the recovery of their land the
self-defense against this illegal and
promote Russian attack and also to work
together on the recovery and the
rebuilding what's this war is over but
the one thing I would note I think it's
incredibly important the world
listens to this
said publicly that the excuses
used to justify his invasion of Ukraine
who are completely legitimate that there
was no risk to Russia there was no
rationale there was no legitimacy for
Russia's invasion of Ukraine so I think
the world should reflect on that but we
will stay focused on the other hand
which is
recovery
and the next question is from Reuters
and it's for secretary have you spoken
directly with your Turkish County Board
regardless session and so what
indications did they give you about a
building application in time for the
business side if not is there a need for
a plan B around the timing of Sweden
well I suppose the uh answer this of
course I have I have the opportunity to
speak with the new Turkish foreign
psychologists this really becomes member
sooner or all the nature of that
position will continue until they come
to us
so this concludes the press conference
but right now we'll be taking interviews
over here thank you very much